Hãy xong mùng chính là tám, các lực lượng tìm kiếm của nạn và năng tích cực ra sóa
vùng biển mũi nè bán gạo sân trà thành của đảnh sâu vụ mũn người bị sâm quân choi vào xa mũn tà năng tám
Tất to được phân chia của bực tìm kiếm, trên khai suy đêm với cuối tâm tìm thấy cái nạn nhân có lại
Chứ đó vào khoảng 1 giờ xa ngày mũn tà năng tám, nhau mũn người đang đi bộ tại cuộc mũn nè
thì bắt ngờ biển một cơ sống lớn của suyển.
Mũn người được tâu cả cực vào bờ, mũn người khác được tâu sóa hãy chính của bùng bài quân cứu,
sau khoảng tám dở choi xa chim biển.
Nạn nhân được cứu cho biến đã thả lòng ngồi, nằm ngờ để suy chi khả năng thật
và mấy mạnh bản được vào mũn phá thự trẻ, kiện còn 2 người mất tích,
cơ lượng trưng năng tích tụng mở giọng phạm vì tìm kiếm chim biển.
Đồng thân vi đọng tâu tuyên hoạt động của gần khu bực khủ trở.